Hi, Data2100 students.
In this video, we are going to
also talk about a new clause called
the HAVING clause, right? The
HAVING clause is another clause in
structured query language, right?
We just talked about GROUP BY,
now let's talk about HAVING.
Okay, so what is HAVING and why
do we use it? So the HAVING
clause is used to restrict which
groups are included in your
output. Okay, I would write that
down. The HAVING clause is used
to restrict which groups are
included in your output. I would
also add to your notes that it
normally 95% of the time includes an
aggregate function. For our purposes
of this class it is always going
to include an aggregate function.
Okay so it having clause will have
some sort of aggregate function inside
of it for this class like count,
sum, max, min and that is very much
that is more universal in terms of
their generally it always has an
aggregate function but maybe for some
more advanced use cases it does not
but for our purposes in this course
it will all right so let's take
a look at it so we know that
selecting from are required for every
select statement we know that where
is conditional expression in terms of
the records right group by is our
aggregate function helper the having
clause is conditional for groups
and then finally we order by and so
we sort for output. So this is the
last of the six clauses for you to
become accustomed to. It
is a little bit more of a
difficult part of our module.
It is a little bit more
challenging, but it's
totally doable. All right.
So in my opinion, it's the most
difficult portion of our SQL module.
So again, if there is an aggregated
field and a non-aggregated field
in the select clause always grouped
by the non-aggregated field.
Now let's tack on this idea of
having. So having modifies the
group by or groups as where
modifies from or records. Okay.
So having and where are similar
in that they have some sort
of conditional expression,
but having looks at groups and
the where clause looks at
records or the from clause. Okay.
So let's take a look
here. Let's jump into
a couple of examples that I've given you.
So the examples I've given
you, so let's just go ahead and
jump into these. So how many
total visit products have been
sold at Overland? That's our
first question. So let's come
over here and take a look. So
how many total visit products?
Oh, I meant to grab my
Overland ERD and DA dictionary.
All right. Okay. So we're going to
be looking at our Viz product table.
So how many total products? So
let's look at our Viz product table.
So this is the quantity of
product purchased on visit. This
is the price of product purchased
on visit. So how many total
products have been purchased?
All right, so let's come over
here and take a look. So I know
I'm going to be querying from
that Viz prod table. So select
star from Viz prod. Again,
this is tracking that these are
products that were purchased
and it's tracking how many were
purchased in the quantity field,
right? Think of these as like
line items. You know, you can go
to Costco and buy six rotisserie
chickens. And if you did that,
then the quantity of this
would be six. Okay. But instead
you just, in this case, they
just bought one pro equipment
product ID. So the product ID
is found in the product table.
We will soon learn how to query
multiple tables at once, but
for now we're limited to
knowing that there was a product
purchased. Um, and then there was
the number that were purchased and
the price of that. All right. So
let's go ahead and see how many total
visit products have been sold at
Overland. So what I need to do here
is I need to not necessarily count
something, right? How many total
visit products I want to some
quantity, right? Because if I was just
counting, then I'm just counting,
right? The number of different products
sold. But in this case here, down
here on line number five, there is
two products that were sold.
Therefore, if I only counted the number
of records here, I know I'm going
to miss out on at least one product
because I must sum quantity together
in case quantity is ever
greater than one. So what I'm
gonna do here is I'm gonna
select sum and then quantity,
okay, as total products.
All right, perfect.
So let's go ahead and run this.
so I see I have 118,297 total products
sold at Overland. So that's how
many total products I have sold
from Overland. Now though I want to
list the total visit products that
have been sold of each of the product
IDs. Okay so I want to know for
each of the different product IDs
how many of those total products
have been sold. So let's go ahead
and take a look here. So now I
want to add in prod ID, right?
That's the product ID in my visit
product table, right? Prod ID,
okay?
So I'm going to say select prod ID,
sum quantity as total products.
Now, pop quiz, will this run?
No, it will not run. I have an
aggregated field, right? And a non
-aggregated field in my select clause.
therefore I'm going to group by
prod ID. Okay, so I'm going to
group by that non-aggregated field.
Now when I run this, I can see
here I have the product ID and the
total number of products. So in
this case, this is a basic tune
-up, if you will. And so, you know,
say that is you go in and they
will wax the snowboard for
you. Maybe they're going
to check your bindings,
whatever that may maybe,
for those of you that
are snowboards or skiers.
So there's 3,130 of those sold.
A lift day ticket, 38,495 of
those sold. So we can see here
what is the most popular selling
products and what is the least
popular selling products.
so now that we've done a problem,
like part A, let's look at,
don't include, now part B,
don't include groups or product
IDs that have sold less than
4,000 products. Okay, if I
take a look at this, I can
see here that the basic tune,
right, has sold less than 4
,000 products. So I don't want
that included in my output.
So let's, how do I write that query?
So I'm going to grab this, I'm
going to select all of that. But in case
though I add on additional products,
if you will, I want to make sure
that, so how would I write this
query to not include groups or product
IDs that have sold less than 4,000
products? So what I would do here
is I would add on my having clause.
So here I'm going to say having,
and they, now remember I told
you that having is, for our
purposes in this class, always going
to have an aggregate function,
and generally that's the case.
that's always generally the case.
So therefore I have sold less
than 4,000 products. So what I
would like to do here is I want to
sell less than 4,000 products.
Well I want to do the same thing
as I did up above and take the
having some quantity right because
this is how I determine the total
products is by summing quantity
and I say that the total
products must be greater than or
equal to 4,000, right, because
it's sold less than 4,000 products.
So now when I run this, instead of having
four different product
IDs appearing to me,
okay, so instead of having
four different ones,
all right, so I put this requirement
on there. Now I'm going to make
sure that I zoom all the way out. I
have to zoom in and out so that you
can make sure you can see it good
on your screen. But I can see here
that I have seven total rows. So when
I zoom all the way out here, I can
see here I had initially seven total
rows. So we can see what the best
-selling product was, which was this
lift day ticket, and I could order
by to figure that out. But I can
also see here that I have the prime
tune and basic tune, right, that
have less than 4,000 products sold.
Therefore, when I run
this query, so instead
of having seven, when I run this query,
we will see here that I now only
have five total products that are,
total, in this case, now they're
groups returned to me, right? So
there's five rows, but they're
really groups, right? They're groups
of a product ID and they're total
products. I only have five now
being returned to me as I set this
requirement so that groups must
meet the requirement of having at
least 4,000 products sold in order
to be included in my output. So
we eliminated two of those groups
that did not meet this conditional
requirement set for groups in
my having clause. Now, some of you
may be wondering, well, Reagan,
why can't we just use, why
can't we just refer to total
products up here, right? I already
renamed it as total products.
Well, so you're probably wondering, let
me copy this query down, paste it again.
Why can't I just do this?
Okay. So if I was to run this,
if I was to run this and
instead of having to do the
aggregate function again,
instead I just ran this.
it says invalid column name total
products but i created in the
select clause so why can i not
refer to it in the having clause
and the reason for that is the
order of processing okay so the
order of writing an sql query is
select from where group by having
an order by okay but the order
of processing, the way that it's
processed, if you will, is that
the from clause is ran first.
So when the server receives
this query, it's saying, oh,
where is the data coming from,
right? So from clause, where is
the data coming from? Oh, it's
coming from the guest table.
What records do I need to eliminate?
That's going to be in the where
clause. What groups do I need to
create? And then what groups do I
need to eliminate? Then we select
the actual fields that are going to
be returned to us. So that in mind,
if I create an alias, which I did
in the select clause, my having
clause runs before the select clause,
right? It's number four to run and
the select clause is number five.
Therefore, I cannot refer to something
in the having clause that was
created in the select clause, okay?
So I cannot refer to the alias of
total products because in the order
of processing, it doesn't know that
total products exist yet, right? So
just keep that in mind that I must
recreate, if you will, this aggregate
function here in the sum quantity
in my having clause. I cannot
refer to an alias created in the
select clause in the having clause.
So we'll talk more and more about
the order of processing, but
that's a question that I often get
from students, so I wanted to
address that right out of the gate in
that we need to basically redo
that aggregate function down here.
All right, everybody, that's
our examples for today.
Thanks so much for being an
awesome class. Take care.